this is raven fellas oh that's so
raven hey brandon it's raven from
arkansas
whooping zooey anyways got
theo's donkey on my screen oh that butt
what joey diaz about to rub on out to it
anyway i don't blame him i bet brendan
would too
probably i have five people to choose
from but i needed to pick
narrow it down to two for you guys
anyway
who's the better dancer chris brown or
ursha baby anyway
[Music]
what is up girl what's up
girl uh oh who was i arguing with the
other night
i was at the comedy store when they're
talking about you have a junk it was me
you and ron taylor
and we were talking about how theo's
gotta but don't cut down
who we brought in uh my girl your girl
but then your opener what's his name
arie manus
all right because we were arguing about
dude doesn't have an ass he doesn't do
squats or deadlifts and everyone's like
no he got to ass
the old guy cakes and then ari came out
with hey
steven asks oh yeah bro yeah i've never
seen it
you always hide in that thing you're
always hiding those cheeks bro
dude let them breathe i'm of age that's
probably why you're not looking at it
dude get the cheekers out bro [ __ ]
clap quack quack hater dude
yeah i know quit hiding that thing bro
hiding it dude i've had back surgery
because of it dude
it's so hard to let i can't lay on my
back at night you got a fat ass huh yeah
this is new it's like
it's like laying on a hillside dude
everyone swore by
too like yeah when i went theo has a
flat ass who went what
i said you're built like a hyena yeah
and then they were like no he's
not and then even r is like oh dude i've
seen that thing in the flesh it is
oh i know he has it yeah that's what
he's looking at my hotel room said he
said it's like two watermelons back
there
what i couldn't believe it because i you
know you're always sitting on it around
me
yeah keep it away from me you creep i'm
just saying dude don't
hide those cheeks it's a shame i wear
shorts today for you
all right well we're getting better but
you got a long jersey out the back dude
that diana bro
yeah hyena getting them cheeks out the
back bro quit hating that [ __ ]
slangaroo boy you know what i'm saying
vernon's trying to think of something
i'm thinking how much money you can make
as a [ __ ]
no you can feel it man it's like kind of
like when a car takes a wrong turn and
goes into a cul-de-sac
and you know they're gonna come back it
comes back out it's the same sound
nothing
you just kind of hear somebody just
beating on the steering wheel a little
in the distance
crazy how loud the silence can be it's
crazy dude
definitely god man don't be mad because
i want you to get your cheeks out on
stage
dude quit thinking about my butt you
adult man
i'm just saying did seven adult men have
an argument about your ass the other day
yeah we did look and i lost that
argument apparently bill the thrill
clinton went to uh
university of arkansas so shout out i
would say
i think probably chris brown she wants
to know who'd win in a fight
better dancer oh god chris brown all day
but i wonder about now though because
chris brown i'm sure oh no
have you seen great he just dropped a
new video with this dying piece
and they're dancing it's just him that
all he really does now is dance and
punch people
but that's what he does well i just know
he's in a lot of lawsuits and he's
probably i can't imagine what it's going
to be like
a lot of those guys just get sued so
much they end up with nothing who was
that guy t-pain just saying i
had nothing he said video he's in a lot
of pain he had
40 million dollars and isn't it and he's
broke now from what though
broke dude i mean had to give his cars
up yeah but what's he been buying with
40 million he bought a bunch of stuff of
bad investments
he said he had a friend who was his
money manager would see things and think
he could
make him better and he'd never made any
of them better and he just bought them
that's on you bro
oh i agree hit the the interesting thing
about it is he doesn't seem
upset about it no he just won the masked
singer he did
yep he was on there yup he won right i
know he's on it yeah he
he won this first season wow so his
career is
looking up who's in there t-pain
really it's just him against himself who
okay yeah that show
looks so strange is it terrible yeah it
looks terrible so bad
uh what's your question oh he's about
dude chris brown all day i i like uh
sure back in the day there's a video of
him going back and forth
is there yeah but a young chris brown
right
but yeah chris brown's way better oh
chris brown
dude this is like who's who's better gsp
or khabib
like he learned from usher and then 2.0
but usher are those jays are why he says
he's hottest one
oscar's smoother though usher is like
silk
and uh what's his name is like a [ __ ]
really fast burlap
chris brown i'm a chris brown fan
are you you seem like you would be dude
underage women dude he gets in a
straight up seventh grade
he gets in a fista cuff with rihanna and
she kind of won the fight and then his
career goes down the drain
yeah but he keeps going back up the
drain though it's like up and down the
drain yeah it is
and we're fan yeah and rihanna's way
tougher dude than chris brown is
yeah i'd rather fight uh less than
rihanna all day yeah
she's zero if she yeah she's yeah she's
a hitter
she's at her she's a hitter i don't care
actually i'll tell this girl this
yeah man they'll honestly do not give a
[ __ ] who's a better dancer
this isn't my expertise they both can
dance i don't give a [ __ ]
you have more insight than you've
probably heard people talk about them
more in your life
than we have so let's go to the culture
corner uh chris brown all day
usher's just old man them knees the
knee's starting to
bang up on him you know cat who do you
like better you're younger
so probably chris brown fan uh i
wouldn't say i'm a chris brown fan but
he's definitely the better dancer wow
chris brown's so talented so
talented you why aren't you chris brown
fan the whole rihanna stuff
um it's a combination of that and i
think his music's just not for me
interesting he doesn't miss for me i
celebrate his whole catalog
he does he have a dick how do you know
uh tosh.now talked about it one day and
brought him on an episode and he showed
it and it's like a [ __ ]
it's beautiful man it's most beautiful
thing i've ever seen oh wow
on some art [ __ ] not on some gay [ __ ] on
some jess you know well known
you're mean bro what do you mean art
[ __ ] like when you see like a naked
woman you're like oh that's nice
you're on some dichelangelo [ __ ] right
now bro you sound like a gay get you a
klondike
yeah you might be homoerotic bruh and
that's all right just want to sculpt it
i don't want to touch
hello it should be seen whatever you
like doug bro clay
to gay bro that's where you headed and
that's fine dude if you want to be gay i
don't care
brennan might be gay dude we don't know
yet dude well we know
jury's still out i'm like that seventh
grade girl with big tits i'm gonna grow
older we'll see what happens
the jury's out in the courtroom waiting
for you to show back up and accept your
sentence dude that's all i'm saying
the jury's been sitting in there milling
it might be me but it might be derek
cause he said chris brown has a
beautiful dancer and he's the one who
validated for your ass cheeks
hard that's a good idea all right dude
i'm all right i believe you
yeah he does he's not built like and he
just got his girlfriend a very short
haircut
and he has his girlfriend on him's
vitamins
there could be more to meet the others
i love old spice dude not the gel
hard stick what else we got 51 went with
usher which is weird
the king and i stand